new details on Captain America the
Winter Soldier Marvel gets closer to
picking its black panther a production
update on ant-man and details on the
Scarlet Witch Quicksilver Avengers 2
crossover it's the summer of Awesome
Episode two for another everybody Iron
Man 3 is out in theaters so I thought
I'd take some time to talk about the
Winter Soldier ant-man Black Panther and
Avengers 2 in the last couple of weeks
there's been a bunch of production
photos released from the Winter Soldier
it shows Chris Evans with Scarlett
Johansson and samuel l.jackson there's
also some anthony mackie photos as the
Falcon part of the reason why he's
spending so much time with Scarlett
Johansson and samuel l.jackson is that
this movie is almost like a shield movie
Captain America is stuck in the present
so he basically has to learn how to live
in this new world Captain America will
deal with some of the issues of being
lied to if you remember in the Avengers
just Whedon actually explained the Agent
Coulson did not die and it was actually
Nick Fury's trick just to motivate them
to action so part of the film will be
dedicated to Captain America just
dealing with the fallout from that like
I said there have been some set photos
of Anthony Mackie as the Falcon he will
actually be Captain America's sidekick
in this movie the character actually
made a big comeback in the comic books
so it should be a lot of fun if you
remember Anthony Mackie also just
starred in pain and gain which he plays
a ridiculous bodybuilder in the movie
Emily VanCamp will also be a SHIELD
agent that works with Captain America I
think of her like a Agent Coulson only
with extra benefits there's also a
rumored cameo from the iron patriot
played by Don Cheadle well we don't know
what the big twists are in this movie my
buddy Grace Randolph on beyond the
trailer actually speculated that Emily
VanCamp might actually be sin the secret
daughter of the Red Skull you can find a
link to her video in the description
below
so obviously this movie is a spiritual
sequel to The Avengers let me know which
other cameos you're expecting in the
comments below personally I think it's
going to be black panther even though
they haven't announced a character yet
remember Captain America won't be
released until 2014 so by that time
they'll probably have a better idea of
who's going to play the Black Panther
character current frontrunner are
chadwick boseman and Morris Chestnut
personally I think that bow
is the likely candidate just because he
recently starred in 42 and had an
amazing performance and I think he'd be
a much cheaper buy for Marvel the really
exciting thing about the Black Panther
movie is that it represents Marvel's
first african-american superhero and the
character has big ties to Captain
America if you're familiar with the
comic books you know the Captain America
shield is made of an alien metal called
vibranium that metal actually comes from
Vulcan de which is where the Black
Panther comes from let me know in the
comments if you think that Black Panther
is going to be the post-credits teaser
in Captain America obviously this movie
isn't going to be out till 2014 so
subscribe to my channel I'll be posting
updates as they're announced obviously
when we get an actor it'll be a huge
deal so we'll be able to find out a
little bit more about what that movie is
going to look like so it's been a while
since we've had an ant-man update and a
lot has happened since then we've had
Avengers we're getting Iron Man 3 and we
got Thor coming at the end of the year
so obviously there are a lot of changes
happening to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and they're going to be some
giant rewrites to ant-man to accommodate
those changes just to keep it in the
continuity of the shared Marvel Universe
and allow for the inclusion of new
spin-off movies like Black Panthers that
they had previously not announced yet
speaking of shared Marvel Universe
there's some new details on Avengers 2
cameos from Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver so during the Iron Man 3
premiere studio President Kevin Feige
actually mentioned that Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch are planned for cameos in
Avengers 2 they did say that even though
that Fox technically owns the x-men
characters these characters had a
special arrangement part of that deal
though includes that they can't mention
magneto
and the characters cannot be a part of
the Avengers even though they are in the
comic books I'm also guessing that
they're going to drop that incest
storyline to so I'm also posting reviews
of Iron Man 3 and star trek into
darkness
they won't include any spoilers I've
already done a couple spoiler episodes
I'll have links to those in the
description I'll also include details on
the post-credits scene that got cut out
of Iron Man 3 in that video too I'll be
posting my Iron Man 3 review today and
my star trek into darkness review
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
that video in the meantime you can click
here to get that Iron Man 3
you and you can click here to watch my
spoilers into darkness to get you ready
for Star Trek thanks for watching bye